a trail of Destruction following rioting
in Sri Lanka soldiers have joined police
to enforce a three-day curfew aimed at
stopping the violence the government's
failure to solve the unprecedented
economic crisis has angered people here
prime minister Mahindra rajapaksa
resigned after weeks of pressure
but protesters say that's not enough and
want his brother who's president to go
to
we are standing here until gotabe
rajapaksha go home and not only that we
are demanding
for the new interim government to
establish new laws under the 21st
amendment and beyond that we need to
abolish the executive presidency
thousands like him had protested
peacefully for more than a month outside
the president's office the but say the
prime minister's supporters attacked
them on Monday
dozens of buses were destroyed in the
Ferocious fighting which followed and
VIP cars dumped in a lake
police investigators and the local
magistrate inspected the damage
trade unions condemned what they
described as a planned attack on
Peaceful anti-government protesters
they bought provincial politicians to
the prime minister's residence and hired
thugs to attack the protesters
we ask that legal action be taken
against Mahindra rajapaksa for setting
fire to this country
trade unions have started a strike and
said won't end until both the president
and government resign and there's a
proper investigation into the attack
that the unrest goes on the homes of
politicians were set on fire and an
assault on the highest ranked police
officer in the western province has
increased concern that the crisis is
spiraling out of control
the defense Ministry has authorized the
Armed Forces to shoot anyone stealing or
assaulting anyone Sri Lanka is facing
its worst economic crisis since
Independence in 1948 and destruction of
this scale it just cannot afford
observers say what adds insult to injury
is that it could have been avoided
Fernandez Al Jazeera Colombo